[Music]
we look back now and I guess him and his
best had a friend had a combo it was
like she was like we're at a restaurant
together like she just come marry two
weeks ago in a new interview with Big
Boy's neighborhood show kim kardashian
opens up about hiding her diamond
engagement ring from Kris Humphries
during a dinner with Kanye West
shortly before ending her infamous 72
day marriage to the NBA star Kim and
Kanye reconnected soon after Kim
returned from her honeymoon with Kris we
end up both at the Soho House and he sat
at my table and he was with his best
friend I was with my best friends
nothing like that and I had my big ring
on because I was married so I'm like
talking with my ring and I talk with my
hands a lot so I'm talking and I just
see him looking at my ring in his hand
his face would just like her broken so I
sat on my hands with one hand
Kim insists that nothing happened
between them until after her breakup but
admits her encounter with Kanye helped
her realize her marriage to Kris wasn't
all she expected it to be nothing went
down nothing happened but then I went to
New York and started filming and I was
like you're right I'm miserable I made
the wrong decision
[Music]
[Applause]